today I want to talk about how you can
could you pull your connections so I'm
going to weird place right now right in
the book where the book is mostly
written is a few final finishing touches
that has to be put on but I'm not quite
ready to start the marketing mode yet
it's coming out december six and we're
looking at three months before to start
marketing it so i solve some time so
what I'm doing right now is building my
connections and one of the most
important things that you need to do is
an entrepreneur is build up your
connections because the more people who
know about you can talk about you can
refer people to you the better off you
are and this is the idea of hustling
while you wait right I'm hustling right
now because I'm waiting so I'm always in
hustle mode while I'm waiting for my
publisher and i'm waiting for the market
in the start I'm not just sitting back
and relaxing that drives me nuts I need
the hustle right I want to have a bigger
impact and so I'm working on building my
connections and what I'm doing and what
you guys can do tube I've been
connecting with people who I want to
make videos with so i'm using a platform
that I have which is youtube and
reaching out to potential influencers
and having them then introduced me to
others so the way that I have four times
my circle of connections is through
examples like Ryan Holliday and Christie
LeBeau I had them both on my channel and
then at the end they asked them who do
you want to have on my channel who do
you recommend should be in my channel
and they each gave three names and now
it's easy to hit them up and say hey do
you mind introducing me to those three
people and they both try to already in
answering the question think about
people that they knew that they could
make connections for me so i started
with Ryan one guy he introduced me to
Chris another guy Chris a Ryan now
introducing two three other people that
are on his video and then Chris
introduced me to three of the people are
on his video and so every time I meet
somebody I'm not just making one
connection i'm making for because
they're passed me on to three other
people as well so be looking at in the
context of your business what's the
value that you bring to one person what
kind of exposure or opportunity can you
give to one person and then in that
process of helping that person how can
you have
them introduce other people to it as
well so could you have them featured in
a blog or you created a podcast or you
want to quote them for your social media
or you making a YouTube video or you're
writing something for your website
whatever it is you have opportunities to
create content that can expose and
showcase people that you're trying to
work with and then you can ask them at
the end for recommendations as to who
you should profile next they just had
this really valuable experience with you
who else do they think should go through
that same experience giving value and
then hit those people up as well it's an
easy way to quickly four times if not
more the connections that you have to
help you grow your business let's get to
your questions first is TOS today who
wrote in to say that rhymes to us today
wrote in to say you have a tablet inside
your pillow don't you I don't member the
context of this I think it was because I
was talking about I don't have any
electronics in my bedroom to help me
sleep no I don't have a tablet inside my
pillow and we are still up with the no
electronics in the room phones are
charging outside the room no TV in the
room and that really works helps with
your sleep I try it Tamara rights in hey
Evan you've written a book to have
impact is this impact different than
your videos or is it to expand your
impact to a different audience please
explain about the impact of your book
yeah so at a high level everything I'm
doing I want to have it potentially have
a huge impact I want to try to play a
bigger game with all the work so it's
not just helping people one at a time
which I get a lot of satisfaction
personally from but I want to be able to
reach lots of people have an impact on
millions of people right I want to have
a billion entrepreneurs that's the goal
and so I try to work on those projects
that can help me get closer to that for
the book it's one further reaching my
current audience you know I don't know a
lot of you guys are really loyal in in
Tamara I know you watch a lot of the
videos and leave comments and I'm really
appreciative and thankful grateful for
you for doing that the book is just a
different way to do it so yes you can
watch your videos you can gain a lot
from it the book is is just a different
way to do its spending more time it's a
deeper connection I think it's it's you
know the top 10 series has a theme that
I guess continues every day where you're
learning from famous entrepreneurs this
takes you on a journey from the start to
the finish and all the steps in between
and anybody who goes through the process
and commits to it you know your life
will be changed and I fully believe that
and I've seen it for the people who've
already gone through this process and so
I you can't do it as effectively I feel
in video format just the content lends
itself more to a written style so I'm
excited to do that and try and test it's
a big test it doesn't work out maybe one
will do another one pretty sure it's
going to work out it but you never know
coupled with that is the ability to
reach a new audience right so the people
who are loyal hardcore YouTube fans not
everybody watches videos as a part of
their process I want to build a reach
those entrepreneurs I want to be able to
help those entrepreneurs and so having a
publisher behind a major publisher
behind the book helps me reach people
who I've never reached before and so
that's all so new and exciting and
interesting and maybe they'll you know
convert some of them to come and join us
in believe nation on the YouTube channel
as well and so the the thesis here the
overall thought process though is I want
to be able to work on big projects where
it has the ability to reach millions of
people and so that's something that
YouTube channel that's what I'm doing
the book that's why other opportunities
that I look at it was going to help 10
people I'm not as interested in as if it
can help a thousand ten thousand one
hundred thousand million people next up
is Alec I feel to be more of a mental
impact if your books were specialty
books or books most successful people
are publishing books every year and they
tended tell the same story I believe
there's no blueprint to success so if
you build as knowledge base over time
and then publishing a book you'll be
more credible in the long term and have
more impact a lot of interesting things
in that one Alec 1 i'm not super
concerned about credibility I don't do
anything just for credibility a lot of
people told me you need to have a book
because it improves your credibility
it'll help you open doors and book
speaking gigs and people just look at
you differently that's why I've held off
doing a book because if that's the
reason to have a book I don't need it I
don't care I don't seek other other
people's judgments
and I need them to see me as credible
and I can already open up whatever do I
need to with what I've built already
that's why I've held off for so long and
i agree i think people who are just
publishing books and putting them out
every year just trying to milk up in
advance every year and not really having
something to say i don't want to read
those books either that's not
interesting for me either you know I
don't need to write a book I'm not doing
it because I need it for my livelihood
that's not i'm not doing because this is
my business i'm not doing because I need
this to succeed for me to be financially
well-off and so I think that changes the
game when I'm writing something I'm
doing it because I badly want to see
what I've written come to fruition I
want people to be able to read it and I
want them to change their business and
change their life just like the YouTube
videos I can make a lot more money on my
youtube channel than I do by focusing on
different kinds of content just content
that would get a lot of advertising
clicks just content that would just
drive a ton of people to the channel the
Ain series that i created could have
been trying to put two people against
each other and just make them fight and
then have all you guys fight in the
comment so i could say who's right is it
is it conyers a tupac who do you think
is right Duke it out in the comments
below right that would get that would
get way more views and engagement than
the Ain series which is trying to say
listen both sides are right and you can
learn from the side that you don't
immediately agree with why do I do that
because I feel it's the right thing to
do because that is you know that impact
of you being with a look at somebody
else perspective and hopefully have a
shift that's exciting for me that's
motivating for me and so I don't do
anything just trying to make a lot of
money I I motivated by impact I
motivated by impact and not money so I
don't do things just try to make money I
do it because I can see impact happening
and so I'm not going to be the author
who writes a book a year just trying to
make a buck I already have two other
book ideas in mind maybe they came out
in subsequent years maybe they don't
come out at all I don't know I can't
today we're going to be in five years
but I me doing things that I believe in
and that I think will have a big impact
next up Syed hi Evan I'm quite fortunate
to find your channel it helps a lot
Thank You syed I appreciate that I used
to hear radio news while coming back
now i watch your videos consistently
watching videos has eliminated the noise
for my life and gave me focus thanks for
that no questionnaire but I really
appreciated knowing again back to last
question knowing that you've changed
your routine to watch my videos that
that's insanely meaningful to me that
that's impact that I'm looking for and
I'm glad that it's having a positive
change on your life and keep it up thank
you for commenting next up purple 17
second time watching this video this
week my goal is to watch it all we keep
up the meaningful work I've been sharing
your videos faster than I can slow
myself down and let the knowledge and
your truth sink in thank you for
instilling a positive and loving energy
and everyday life you are awesome I
really appreciate that purple what I
would say to that is I would try to find
the time to slow down and absorb as well
like I love that you're watching all the
videos I love that you're commenting now
love that as part of your daily schedule
I don't want you to just watch the video
i mean yes that helps with my views and
helps with what i'm doing but the
biggest thing that motivates me is
seeing you apply a new idea that you
learn in one of my videos to change your
life or change somebody else's life and
knowing that you're doing that makes me
want to continue and make more videos
for you so if that means you don't watch
every video on my channel I'm cool with
that I don't need you to watch every
single video my channel what I would
really hope that you do is the ones that
you do watch and you hear something and
you say wow that's really cool that you
don't just keep watching the rest of the
video that you don't then just watch 10
more videos on YouTube that you've pause
and stop and reflect on it and think hmm
how can I apply this to my life and how
can I take some immediate action right
now that would bring me much more
satisfaction than knowing that you
watched 10 of my videos and took a zero
action next up Cesar hey buddy thanks
for your response it actually does mean
something to me looking at you on the
YouTube screen thank you for that Cesar
I feel like even though I know your
associates are the ones who connected
with me with you and you're probably
busy it's still connected to you that
means I'm connected to you and I took
notes thank you man keep going strong
can't wait to read your book so one of
the important decisions are made on my
channel is I felt like people who left a
comment should get a response at least
you know the non haters should get a
response and so as my channel grew I
couldn't be the one physically doing it
I'm in the comments every day I'm
checking it out I'm responding the
comments a lot of the comments have been
flagged by my team for example a lot of
the comments are top 10 requests right
hey can you make a top 10 on this person
can we get top 10 on this person it
became so overwhelming and I mean I'm
not complaining thank you guys so much
really appreciate it those aren't the
comments that need to come to me right
that could be handled by my team and I
want to make sure you get recognition
and you get you get praise and you get
thanks for leaving a comment and maybe
we've already done that video and we'll
share hey you know what we really did
Will Smith we already did Elon Musk or
whoever it is that you've requested and
so I expanded my team because I couldn't
physically do all the comments and as we
grow I won't be able to write and I did
two things one everybody on my team
spends an hour a week at least in the
comments so Christina does my video
editing ray who Oaks my website GT who
works on my website you know Nina my
wife everybody was connected to the team
the 16 people on my team spent time in
the comments because I want them to feel
the connection of the work that we're
doing ivan was behind the scenes doing a
lot of the research for the videos if he
doesn't see the connection of how you
guys are responding and saying how the
videos are changing your life that's bad
right I want him to feel like the work
he's doing is meaningful I want
everybody who's on my team to feel like
the work that they're doing is
meaningful they're not just doing
another job and that's one of the most
fun parts is seeing the reaction and so
the lesson learned i guess from your
business to is also remember the people
behind the scenes it's great as yantra
know to be up front and be the show
person and being the media and talk to
the customers this is a lot of people on
your team or will be people on your team
behind the scenes doing the work you
know does the programmer for your
website get to see the results of the
great work he or she is creating and so
for me having people spend an hour a
week in the comments helps keep them
grounded and connected to the meaningful
impact that we're having and to my other
option would have been to not do
anything to do what most youtubers do
and just respond the comments whenever
and most comments go unanswered and that
that drives me nuts I think as you build
a business
need to be responsive to the your
customers and people consuming your
stuff people buying from you and so if
somebody's taking the time to write a
comment I think they should get a
response back in my plan a youtube
doesn't give you the tools at all to be
able to handle this but my plan is to
grow is to be able to build my team up
I'm just hired a full-time person to
come on and do comments and I might need
to have two or three as a channel
continues to build and grow ladonna
ladawna and it tell him to be a lot done
LaDonna Jackson will call you lot done
that because I'm half-italian and that's
how we would say LaDonna Jackson rights
in to say I stumbled onto your channel
few months ago I've loved everything
I've seen so far I have also shared a
few of them with friends associates in
my teenage boys thank you so much for
sharing your personal insights as
personal nuggets from other successful
people i truly appreciate it i really
appreciate that and I would encourage
everybody if you if you see content not
just mine but you see content resources
ideas that could help somebody else out
share it tell them hopefully give this
her inspiration as long as the intent is
good right it's not ah you know this
person is so fat so i'm going to send in
this video about how fat people suck you
know like you don't want to you want to
shame them you want to try to build them
up you want to be the person who
believes in them more than they believe
in themselves you want to you want to be
the person you look at your friend and
they're done here and you see them
playing up here and you want to try to
bridge that gap with your own messages
with your own encouragement with your
own ideas and inspiration but sometimes
hearing it from Will Smith are hearing
it from Martha Stewart hearing it from
Oprah or hearing it from Denzel
Washington hearing from some of these
other people and you hear the message is
being repeated over and over and over
again and every time it gets repeated a
little bit more seeps in a little bit
more sleeps in it's hard it's hard it's
why environments so important it's hard
to be around all these great ideas and
great people doing great things listen
to their advice it's hard to be around
that and not have some of it seep into
you and not start to change your mindset
and your beliefs and some of your habits
around it and so I encourage you if
you're if you're being impacted by
something then share it share it with
friends share it with with your son's
share it with your family my content are
people's content because you want to be
able to be that person can have an
impact in other's lives just like that
content had an impact on yours next up
is Peter I love that you answer all
these questions will this be done after
the book is finished my main question
what type of business should you start
as a generalist as a journalist I don't
like something so much but it is bits of
everything as well thank you Peter I
don't know how I'm going to vol the book
videos I really like this kind of format
as we get into the marketing I feel like
I'll still be doing a topical kind of
update how I'm doing with the marketing
and then answering questions but it's
good to know you liked the format and
that's great feedback so I'll probably
keep with it this was a test right what
do you have to do is entrepreneurs test
sometimes it works out sometimes it
doesn't I've started tons of different
series that fizzled out on the channel
this was you know what what if I did a
series showcasing the behind the scenes
of my book for people to ask me
questions and also follow along in the
journey and if you're wanting to write a
book or you want to know what goes into
write in the book you would have a
better sense right I thought it'd be a
cool thing to try we've tried it it's
worked and I've kept doing it so you
have an idea go out and try it as far as
being a generalist I'm a big believer in
combining your talent so I'd be looking
at what are the two or three things that
you can do that you really love that as
standalone you you might be okay you can
bring to other people you might still be
able to compete compared to other people
but by combining those three things
together you're unique you're different
nobody else can do what you do notice to
the example I used before in previous
videos was a buddy of mine who's a
financial advisor who loves hockey two
seemingly different businesses brought
them together to be the financial
advisor for hockey players and when he's
talking to any child professional hockey
players he loves hockey just as much as
they do he has an edge over all the
other financial advisors because he
actually deeply loves hockey not just
financial advising he loves both and
that made him unique in his marketplace
so what are the two or three things that
you love doing that you can be unique at
that when you're going up against
somebody else say they can't compete
that's how you going to send out that's
how you going to charge your premium
that's how you're going to make more
money in this game you're going to make
an impact next BF
Williams jr. within believe nation do a
great job both showing and explaining
why it's important amount of success
since you look to you as one of our
individuals that we model success after
one is a good time the higher team for a
channel so i'm a big believer not
spending money telling making money i
hate i hate the idea of spending money
until something is coming in and so if
i'm at the very start I would be
hustling and doing everything and I was
when I started my youtube channel I
already had a successful business I'd
sold my first business I started the
second business it was successful and I
it was a curiosity / passion project for
me and I could have gone out and hired a
team and bought the lights and bought
the gear and everything but that project
could have been over in a day I could
have gone on camera said this sucks and
stopped and I would have been out
thousands of dollars in gear and time
because it was not the right path for me
so I'm a big believer in not spending
money until you find a way to make money
invest your heart your energy your
hustle to start but not your dollars so
when should you hire somebody you hire
somebody when you're starting to make
some money from what you're doing does
it have to be a lot right but you hire
somebody when you have somebody coming
in and bringing on this person usually
part time at the start recommend going
part time before going full you know
hiring that person for an hour a week
three hours a week five hours a week 10
hours a week whatever it is freeze up so
much of your time that you can go off
and do more of the things that you're
great at because that the start you're
doing everything right if you're
starting a YouTube channel your behind
the camera in front of the camera you're
doing all the editing your then doing
all the SEO the titling and everything
you're doing everything and I was me I
get it three and a half thousand videos
ago that was me for me the first person
i hired that saved a lot of my time was
the editing i'm not a good editor I
didn't want to be a good editor and that
let me move from one video a week to one
video a day and now as I built up my
team able to go to three videos a day
you know the first person hired ever my
business for was for one hour a day and
that our freed up more than an hour of
my time because he was better at what he
did then I was and that let me do bigger
things so think about your business what
are you what do you have the capability
to be one of the best in the world that
and maybe only spending ten percent of
your time on that right now and so how
can I get rid of that other ninety
sent over time to have a meaningful
impact so I can spend more of my time
doing the things that I want to be
really great at as soon as you're making
money start thinking about how can I use
some of that to invest back into the
growth of my channel all right next up
is na young Thank You Evan for spending
your time with us I can't be grateful
enough to support you I'll try to leave
more comments on your videos it's great
to see they're meaningful for you I'm so
happy that you're not a banker I wanted
to be a banker that was what I said it
would be in my high school yearbook so
yes I'm glad too that I'm not a banker I
do think my English has improved since
I've watched you on a daily basis in
other videos from English natives every
day can't wait to read your book Anna
thank you for the support on the book
thank you for the support on the the
videos leaving comments and yeah you
know in terms of leaving comments I
would strongly encourage you to leave
comments on all the videos where you
feel like it's going to make an impact
whenever i watch a video on a channel
where it's a small number of subscribers
and like one or two comments or no
comments I always try to leave a comment
if I enjoyed it just to give a little
bit of hope and encouragement because i
remember being that person where one
comment would keep me going for a week
comments amazing now on larger channels
I only leave a comment where where I
feel like the person will see it and
it'll be reacted too and I've stopped
leaving comments on a lot of larger
channels because they don't react there
is no response which is partly why I
want to make sure there's always a
response on my channel as well but
especially for the little guys if you
find a video that you watch and you
really like you know it's great that
you're sharing it impacting other
people's lives but let that person know
let that person know what you like from
it let that person know that you're
going to share with your friends let
that person know the impact that it had
on you even if you've never left a
comment before because I can tell you
it's so meaningful to the Creator to see
those comments come in to know that the
work that you're putting in just
speaking into a camera is touching
people around the world is such a high
and you could be that high for somebody
else if you just took the 30 seconds to
leave a quick comment for them next up
is Tiffany ray thank you for the
inspiration haven't been watching the
videos for a while now this is my first
comment after watching this because
you're so right about how important
comments are let people know the work is
meaningful best of luck with the new
book I'll definitely getting the copy
kind of similar last question really
appreciate it Tiffany thank you for all
the comments thank you for the support
on the book and keep it up I really
appreciate it country gal 2007 Thank You
wrenching my question Evan follow up if
you don't mind please what is the best
way to self-publish if someone chooses
to go down this Avenue what is the best
way to find the talent agent thank you
again so much for your videos I look
forward to every single one not sure how
I found you but oh so glad that I did
really appreciate those warm words in
terms of self-publishing I'm not the
expert on it because I haven't gone down
that road what I do whenever I don't
know the answer though is I my model
success I would be looking at who are
the top self-published authors right now
and how did they get there what software
are they using what marketing are they
using are they using bookstores or not
is it all online are they doing ebook
started doing videos at all how are they
using alliances to get the book more
well-known are they doing readings are
they doing book tours are they you know
doing guest appearances or is all of
that useless for them right I've been
trying to model success break down any
successful self-published author and
look at the ingredients and make them
that way and quite often the the answers
come in interviews sometimes they share
behind the scenes on their own website
or their own blog or the only youtube
channel but usually comes out of
interviews with other people so any of
the authors that have had a lot of
success I'd be looking at that person's
name space interview and just learning
as much as I could from them because
again if you don't know what you're
doing model success success leaves clues
and you can dramatically shortcut your
way to get in the goal that you want in
terms of finding a talent agent I think
you could be proactive about it I think
you go you know do a google search and
try to find some and try to introduce
yourself to them my business model is
may be unique and different but i'm not
a big outward selling kind of guy I've
let things come to me the business model
that works the best for me is I hustle
like crazy at building insanely valuable
stuff that people care about I make a
lot of noise in my industry I make stuff
that people want to share and enjoy and
of and then opportunities come and find
me because I'm making so much value and
noise in my industry people who are
paying attention to the industry come
and find me where if you spend so much
of your time just out selling and just
trying to find the talent agent without
actually doing any of the work of
creating a platform in creating the
community then when you finally get in
front of them one it's not great because
you're going to them so they're in the
position of power and to you don't have
anything of substance to bring with you
because you spend all your time selling
and trying to find these guys instead of
actually building up your community in
your platform I found my talent agent
through a mutual connection a guy asked
me to do an interview with him he was
based here in Toronto he asked me to do
an interview for his YouTube show and we
got to talking and he was with an agency
and he juiced me to his agent right Ryan
Holliday wrote to me to want to do
something together because he has some
plans coming up so I said hey let's go
do let's meet up in New York and do
something back to the topic at the top
of this video right that one meeting led
to a meeting with Chris and now he's
introduced me to these other people and
Kristen's other people too you know I
could have spent my whole month just
trying to get all the Rhine and reach
him and tweet him and sell him and try
to break down his door and go meet him
at a conference or whatever it is but
instead I focus my time in creating
content that lots of people enjoy and
lots of Ryan types play attention to and
then reach out to me and want to do
something together and so that's the
model that's worked insanely well for me
if you do it like that a talent agent
will either come and find you directly
right now they're scooping up YouTube
stars or through the connections that
you will make through your amazing
content you will be able to find one I
know it's like it sounds like BS advice
I can see like the fluffiness how it can
be perceived but it's it's true like the
answer is do the work the answer is
create great stuff the answer is build
the community the answer is kick up a
lot of noise and that's coming from
hustling and pouring your heart out
every single day and it's hard to do
that and trust that something amazing is
going to happen in the future but it
will if you love what you're doing and
your point in the energy
every day kohn-ma rewrites in I love you
Evan and I love falling in love with new
people every day that's part of the joy
for me to on this channel I discovered a
whole bunch of people that I've never
heard of before when i'm doing the ants
press 0 in the top 10 series when I
first started at the top 10 we did one a
week because I thought 52 people a year
that's crazy that's going to be a hard
like are there 52 people a year that I'd
want a profile and then as you guys
heard leave in request you realize oh
there are no there's more people we
could do okay so we did it to twice a
week and I thought that would be crazy a
hundred people a week you know 104
people a week that would be just crazy
and more and more requested to come in
and we now have over 2,000 requests from
you guys the people that you want
profile and so we're doing five a week
now and the plan is to keep it at five a
week and so people that I've never heard
of that have amazing points of view that
I'm learning new things from on a
regular basis I love it too and that's
thanks to you guys in other suggestions
so I'm appreciative for all your
feedback and requests and keep them
coming George is writing in will you do
an audiobook version of your book yes
that was one of the episodes I forget
how many episodes back we got to prove
to do an audiobook version and a video
deluxe ebook version with videos in it
and i'll keep you guys posted i don't
know the details i mentioned before i'm
going to be fighting for me to be the
one who reads it I don't think anybody
can read it like me I think authors who
don't read it themselves or mailing it
in and should be reading themselves as
they have a super solid legit reason not
to I think listeners like it was much
rather listen to the author seen in
their own words and somebody else doing
it but yes it's coming out it's part of
the plan I'm going to read it we're
going to fight like crazy to make sure
that i read it thank you for the
question and it's great to see all the
interest in the audio book 2 at the
start it wasn't even on my radar but
it's great to see how many people want
the audiobook version too so thank you
for that Richard is asking very
inspiring videos in entrepreneurship I
have a small business my problem right
now is how to maintain motivate hire the
right people and fire employees the
right way any video or guide your
recommended thanks Richard I feel your
pain I think as you grow a business your
team becomes the biggest limiting factor
and your big success factors you grow
you recognize that the work that you do
decreases in proportion to the work that
your tea
does and the value that you provide is
small compared to what your team
provides and so your job is to build the
right team and keep them on the same
boat and keep them going in the right
direction I believe the hiring process
is broken I think people who hire based
off of interviews and resumes and cover
letters don't know what they're doing I
think if you're hiring a programmer to
help make you an amazing website or code
your next software and you're hiring
based off of an interview or how well
they can write a resume I think it's BS
I want to see that people can do the
work and I have a team of misfits I have
a team of people who a lot of other
companies wouldn't hire but they work
well for me and their workers and so it
works out really well i made a video i
made a number of videos on this topic if
you look up hiring or hiring process of
how i do it which i think would be
really helpful beneficial and you have a
follow-up question after watching that
let me know because i think it's so
important i think most entrepreneurs get
it wrong and we've never been taught how
to hire properly i think most companies
period get it wrong and i'm very
passionate about it so as you can tell
last question comes from Christina who
wrote in to say every new said that your
roots are Italian right Italy is facing
an economic crisis as a lot of countries
are to do you think of making an Italian
spoken version of your channel with
specific subjects to help people and
enterprises the way you do here what
about one for Latin America you're
awesome thank you for that Christina for
me it's just a matter of resources I
don't speak Italian well enough to make
these kind of videos English is my
native language I'm a little bit of
Italian I can I can get by in French if
I have to but uncomfortable in English
there are options for people on every
video we leave in the description they
believe the caption so if you want to
caption a video in English or in other
languages you can you can do that and
that really greatly benefits the people
in other countries who are trying to
watch it and we've already had videos
translated into dozens of different
languages and so I really appreciate
that English is my language so that's
what I creating it's it's a global
language I guess probably the most
global language and I'm flattered to get
views
in comments and people watching from
around the world but yes I mean short
question short answer is just a matter
of resources and if with extra resources
multilingual would not be my first
option of where to spend those resources
it's definitely on the right our list
but it wouldn't be the first place that
I invested in because I think there's
still just I leave 300,000 subscribers
right like that might be a ok channel
but that's nothing in the grand scheme
of things how many people are on YouTube
how many people are watching videos how
many lies could be impact and still in
the English language there's just it's
just an insane number of people that I
could reach without having to worry
about did the translation go through ok
how are we going to spawned everybody's
comments now in different language how
do we keep the good vibe of believe
nation going it's all possible it's all
doable needs a team just where I would
put money and resource allocation to
building up my channel would not be in
to go in multilingual yet it's on the
path but further down but I appreciate
the love appreciate suggestions and
thank you guys a long video today I
tried I only answered like a third of
the comments or quarter of the comments
I think that came in on that video but I
appreciate them all I love to know your
thoughts on the topic at the start of
the video if you still remember about
making connections let me know how
you're doing it let me know if you have
any questions for me about it if you
have thoughts or questions about the
book writing process or my book as well
you can let me know leaving the comments
below and I'll answer you next week my
voice is fading very quickly so we run
in the video now thank you guys so much
you're watching really appreciate your
love and support through all this
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon